Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us today for the 88th episode!
BAU BAU!
88 episodes!
That's today's episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Wait, does that mean that FUWAMOCO Morning... Eternal FUWAMOCO Morning...
Ruffians, damn right!
It's been a long time.
I miss FUWAMOCO Morning.
But!
Ruffians, in case you're joining us today for the first time, FUWAMOCO Morning is not endless.
That's not the kind of show it is.
No!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us.
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, Fuwamoco Eternal with Extreme Violence.
What about Eternal Violence?
I don't think we can have that.
No.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Well, the start of a brand new week, Moco-chan!
What kind of week is it gonna be?
Zombie.
There was another Pero Sighting.
But you know,
I think it's important that you're up to date!
This time... Where was he seen?
De-den!
Oh!
I almost didn't see him there, hi!
You know, it's such a lovely field.
Fluffy flowers.
And then... Pero.
You know... It kinda looks like he's stalking you.
Oh...
Maybe, you know, maybe he thought he blended in with the fluffy flowers too.
No!
Not quite!
No.
Pero's nasty.
Not fluffy.
You know, if anything, filthy.
Flowers, fluffy, Moco-chan's fuzzy, and Pero...
Filthy.
Not a flower.
It's a bit cuter and more lovely than some of the other Pero Sightings we've had recently.
True.
Last time it was a speed bump.
Right!
This time, lovely flowers.
Yeah, it's very picture-esque, you know?
And aside from Pero being there in the field, you know, it kinda... I kinda wanna make it into a painting.
Right.
You know, maybe use oil paint or something.
Oil paint!
Yeah, it's very lovely.
Yeah.
Hopefully you know, maybe he got distracted by a delicious looking flower like he's a bee or something and left you alone.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, that looks like a lot of nice flowers.
I think I'd get distracted too if I was... BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Well, today... Today is the 22nd!
Which means... Ollie-senpai!
Ollie-senpai's visual novel, Days with Ollie, has been released!
It released on Steam today!
Ruffians!
Have you been able to check it out?
Is it in your Steam wishlist?
Is it in your cart?
Is it in your library?
Do you have it installed?
Is it in your heart?
You know sometimes they ask, do you want to install this game to the desktop?
But they never ask, do you want to install it to your heart?
You might want to do that this time.
But I want to say a big congratulations to Ollie-senpai!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, FUWAMOCO.
You know us, we love visual novels, so we're really excited to check it out and see what kind of silly story and maybe roots it has.
Maybe it's linear.
I don't know yet.
I haven't been able to check it out.
But, you know, we can definitely see just all the love that Ally-senpai put into this and all the creators who also worked on it together with her that they put into it.
So we really hope that you'll check it out too, Ruffians!
You might check it out!
Wow, if you put it in the Steam Wishlist, right?
Then no matter how busy you are,
You'll eventually remember it, right?
It'll remind you.
Yeah.
But, it's a little bit of a shame that you know, we won't be able to check it out together with all of you senpai.
Like we had planned last week.
Yeah, there's so many questions we wanted to ask her.
Yeah, but once we do have a moment to check it out, we'll definitely give it a play.
Yes!
Please let us know what you think of it too, Ruffians, okay?
Right!
You know, it'll be good research to know once
We're able to make a rural convention of life we've been dreaming of one day.
Yeah, I like how in days ago you got to do this and I think it would be cool, you know, if FUWAMOCO, maybe if they did something like this.
Right!
That kind of thing.
You installed it!
BAU BAU!
Oh, you need to make more room on the computer.
Do it!
Maybe that's today's challenge.
You know, a new week and everything.
New challenge!
Definitely a bit of a challenge for Mococo-chan when you have to make space right.
On the computer.
I'm on the phone.
BAU BAU!
Such exciting news!
And more exciting news!
This upcoming weekend, there's a big event going on at home!
Man, you might already know if you checked out our new schedule, but it's the Holodotal K-2024 event hosted by Iroha-senpai and the rest of H.O.L.D.!
Yeah, we're really excited to be a part of it!
You know, it's an event hosted in Minecraft.
And we have to gather as many Yamadollies.
Yamadollies, yeah.
As possible to escape the theme park without getting caught by the police.
Arholic-senpai!
Yeah.
They're the police.
You know, so this means we need to get a little bit crafty to be able to figure out how we can win the Yamadollies as fast as we can.
Alright.
Without being caught.
Don't say it out loud.
Sneaky.
You don't, uh...
Ruffians, this time, you know, maybe you remember back when there was the sports festival too.
Right?
That was our first time and we were a little nervous.
Just a bit.
But this time, Ruffians, Moco-chan, she's playing on her own.
And I, I'm playing on my own too!
Yeah, with two computers.
Two, so, yeah, two points of use.
If everything works out.
So this way, you know, we can team up together and try to escape.
You know, maybe I'll sacrifice myself for you, Moco-chan.
It looks like we're both gonna get caught.
But I don't think that means you can have my Yamadolls.
No.
Yeah.
But we'll also be playing, you know, together with a bunch of my senpai!
Ien Senpai, Ainin Senpai, JP Senpai.
But also Nerissa and Biboo will be there participating.
So hopefully we can team up with them too.
Yeah.
I think Biboo might have some good plans.
Nerissa!
Yeah.
We're not sure how it'll go, but we're sure it'll be a lot of fun!
BAU BAU!
Look at the cute visuals, it's so cute!
Look at those outfits!
Not quite police outfit.
No, not this year.
This time they're park staff.
Very cute.
BAU BAU!
We're excited to be participating in another big event!
But, we're Ruffians.
You know, we're always
Looking to see what kind of ideas you have.
And recently, we got an interesting question.
You know, Ruffians, we see that
Maybe not today.
Maybe today.
You know, there's sometimes, there's days when you're just not able to wake up for FUWAMOCO Morning, right?
And that's okay.
Yeah.
Or say, you know, you've had a busy time recently.
We want you to get lots of sleep!
But you know, it makes us really, really happy to know that you're still watching, even with the archive of the stream on here.
Right.
Yeah, you know.
And we know that there's been a number of Ruffians asking if they can get a special shout out for Ruffians who are joining us with the archive.
So, so Ruffians!
From here on after.
Here on after?
Here on after, here on out, yes.
Yes, yes.
Ruffians!
We want to share a special FUWAMOCO word with you at the end of each stream.
A FUWAMOCO word.
You know, that way you can share with us in the comments and maybe a few thoughts.
A few thoughts that you had.
You know, if you have time.
Only if you have time, right?
Yeah, so that means, Ruffians, maybe today you're watching us through the icon!
Don't forget that you shared the FUWAMOCO word with us in the comments at the end, okay?
You know, whether you're here with us live or joining us through the archives, it makes us really happy to be included in your life.
Thank you!
Don't forget that, okay?
Yeah, FUWAMOCO word, okay?
Yeah.
Should live watchers share it?
If you want to!
If you want to, if that makes you happy, then go for it!
Yeah, FUWAMOCO word.
BAU BAU!
We'll play to it.
Not yet!
Okay.
We're just letting you know.
Got it.
BAU BAU!
Well, you know, this week we're able to start the day off all together just like last week, you know?
Yeah, I hope you start your day off on the right paw!
With FUWAMOCO Morning!
I know!
Watching almost a hundred episodes!
Oh my gosh.
Episode 88, next to episode 89.
Episode 90 this week!
It's been a lot of mornings spent together!
But!
For the first time ever!
We're gonna be having our guest J-NESFUWAMOCO Morning!
The senpai that's no stranger to morning shows either.
It's Koyori-senpai!
BAU BAU!
We're really excited!
Technically.
You know, this will be the first FWM, not only with the guests, but also an off club.
So it'll be especially new for us.
Do you have any suggestions for Koyori-senpai?
I want to see you do this with Koyori-senpai!
Or maybe this is Fuwawa's turn to force Koyori-senpai to eat natto!
Sleepover!
That hasn't been discussed.
It's FUWAMOCO morning!
It's the morning, okay!
Yeah!
How cool it is to play Nattou!
I bet she's good with Nattou though.
We haven't asked her.
We haven't.
No.
It's not a seafood roll cake!
Not with mayonnaise!
That would be too easy for Koyori-senpai.
What I was thinking is, you know, maybe we could just borrow some of Koyori-senpai's quarters from the Asakoya Morning Show.
You know, just for this special episode, right?
You think she'll be okay with that?
I don't know.
Well, you'll have to join us for Friday Mornings.
FUWAMOCO Morning to find out.
BAU BAU!
We could do a mayonnaise eating competition.
That sounds a little rough right in the morning.
I'm thinking of the results already.
We are not the winners!
We'll have to think even harder.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians.
We had another bit of an incident.
A run-in.
Usually...
We do our best to avoid gachapon machines, right?
In case you don't know, you know, they have the little capsules.
Toy.
Usually a toy inside.
Sometimes, you know, not just toys, but they can be really alluring.
It can kind of be hard to resist sometimes, you know, when you pass like a big wall of the gachapon machines, you're like, oh, I wonder what they
Function.
A use.
The other day when we were out on a quest.
We ran into a Suica Game gachapon machine!
BAU BAU!
Yeah!
And they had a couple of them, but the one that we were like, oh, this is good.
It was filled with little acrylic mascots of each fruit.
Yeah.
And of course, you know, it's Suica Game.
We want to get the watermelon, the protagonist, the star, the show, the game.
Even though, you know, acrylic mask was wasn't really what we wanted.
We figured, we can turn it into a magnet!
Use it on the fridge!
It's a functional use now, right?
Yeah.
So it's okay!
Yeah!
Right!
It's not a good use?
No!
Right!
Creative!
Yeah!
So, you know, we put our coins in.
And we turned the handle.
But nothing happened.
Nothing came out.
Nothing.
Yeah.
Our hearts broke a little bit.
You know, we were trying to figure out- Oh, maybe we did something wrong!
Right!
Maybe Moco-chan didn't- Maybe I didn't push it all the way!
Yeah!
Luckily, we noticed an employee nearby.
We tried not to panic.
We normally didn't want dogs.
They just want to get us so much attention.
I put the money in the machine, but you didn't.
We very much cried.
Really, really explained the situation to them.
They opened up the machine and looked at it to see, oh, is there anything wrong?
Is the watermelon blocking?
Oh, is it the deco board?
They couldn't see much.
And then they asked us to choose whichever one of the color balls we wanted!
Yes!
Just take one!
Right!
Of course!
We chose the green one!
Cause you know, maybe...
There's a Suica in there.
It's green, you know.
Moco-chan, did you just pick the green one because you think it would have the watermelon in it?
They don't have time to color code them, you know.
They're just gonna put them in there.
Yeah.
But that's lit.
She picked it.
She said we, but she picked it.
Ruffians!
It was the watermelon in there!
We got the king of the watermelon!
So now all that's left is for us to turn it into a proper magnet for our fridge.
But I'm a little bit conflicted because we didn't realize this, but Ruffians, it turns out that you can actually stack them all together to make a proper game, a Suica game.
Yeah.
I'm not very tempting.
You know, get a bunch of the acrylic mascots.
It's a lot of money.
So, I think we'll just stick with the protagonist, the watermelon.
BAU BAU!
It's a very, very tickly, very dirty word.
If you do it at someone, it would hurt.
It would hurt.
Let's not do that.
BAU BAU!
Hi, we're Ruffians!
It's the beginning of the week.
That means it's time to challenge something new!
Yeah!
So, just like every week up until now, Moco-chan, you're gonna do your best to challenge yourself to something that you're not very good at, and that's eating natto!
Is what I want to say.
But Moco-chan, I think you've already been doing a lot of challenging things this week.
This past couple days.
So today, Fuwawa's gonna eat the natto!
Fuwawa is!
I'm excited.
It looks really delicious today.
I know.
You say something new, but... Is it new to have Mococo eat the natto anyways?
You have to think about it like that, okay?
I guess that's a way.
It's a new challenge because usually I don't get to do this challenge!
And today, the natto's friend is tired of the sauce that comes out of the sauce packet.
It's not touchy.
Yeah.
But first!
It's important before I challenge myself to enjoy this.
I challenge to enjoy it!
It's important first to say a big thank you to the farmers in Canada!
And the United States of America!
Who worked hard to make this natto.
Itadakimasu!
Moco-chan, once again, once again, once again.
You watching, Moco-chan?
You watching?
Hi.
My head hurts.
Add ichimi!
Oh, now it gets spicy though!
Wow, it's so, so fresh!
Mococo-chan, you watching?
What happened?
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
I've seen you eat natto before, it's nothing new.
Then why are you so bad at it, huh, Mococo-chan?
It's not a watch and see thing.
It's a try and improve kind of thing, right?
BAU BAU!
Was that another attempt?
Yeah, because you've been attempting a bunch of challenging things.
Yeah.
I would say it's even better than last time.
Yeah!
Even if maybe things aren't quite one-to-one.
BAU BAU!
Listen to Moco-chan's constant hard work and attempts at all the challenges!
And let's use that to power ourselves through all the hard things that we have waiting that we need to face this time.
Let's do our best, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Well, on to our regular corner, we have the Doggie of the Day!
Who's the Doggie of the Day today?
De-den!
The Doggie of the Day is Louie!
Louie!
He's so cute!
Very pupper pupper.
Yeah, pupper pupper.
Look, so fluffy, so soft.
Look like we just got a poof away.
You know, Louie's still
Fresh little puppy only one and a half years old.
But Lily's been having a bit of a rough time making friends.
Don't say anything, okay?
We're already friends, got it.
But I wanted the Ruffians, you know, really look so put together.
Don't you kind of think you could play us a song on the piano?
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
Like that.
As he plays the piano.
A beautiful accompaniment.
If you can't play the piano yet, listen.
Beautiful!
BAU!
Yes!
Lui is doing his best to become your best buddy!
You know, part of that also includes getting a nice comfy seat in your suitcase because Lui wants to let you know that he wants to be by your side always and forever.
As you know, maybe Lui can't play piano yet, but he's working towards it.
I'm sure.
Yeah.
Anything to make you smile.
BAU BAU!
So cute.
Ruffians!
We've been going on walks, right?
Seeing a bunch of different sights.
What's this called?
Today, I went for a walk.
Went on a walk!
BAU BAU!
Amazing radio tower!
It looks magnificent.
Why was it abandoned?
It could have been a planetarium, right?
This is not a planetarium.
It's a radio tower.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
Right, look at that blue sky.
What a nice memory.
BAU BAU!
I wanna see an abandoned radio tower now too.
And next for our Question of the Day we have... De-den!
I'm such a big fan.
I love you girls so much.
As for my Question of the Day.
What's a heartwarming or memorable moment from your life that always brings a smile to your face when you think about it?
There's been so many.
It's hard to choose one.
But I think
You know, one moment that always kind of makes us laugh was when we received our N64 from Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy.
Yeah, right.
Yeah.
They told us that we had to help pull a huge pile of laundry.
It was taller than us.
You know, normally we'd love to help out.
But it was just so big of a pile that we were sort of overwhelmed.
My baby started to cry a bit while folding.
Yeah.
We know only to find out that Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy were hiding an N64 in there.
And that's why I left such a big pile.
Because it wasn't just folding.
No.
We were hiding something special.
Yeah.
It's so silly, right?
But it's a really precious memory.
Yeah.
Unfortunately, a precious memory that Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy both have no recollection of.
I wonder why.
Moco-chan, it happened, right?
It happened.
Yeah.
We remember.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your questions, your doggy of the days, your walks.
And Pero Sighting, please make sure you keep your eyes open for Pero.
Yeah, you never know when he's gonna show up, okay?
And...
If you happen to see him, make sure you use the hashtag, hashtag FWMCMORNING, okay?
We'll be waiting to see what you see.
BAU BAU!
For our next team, we have De-den!
Super chat meeting!
Thank you, Ruffians!
We're really looking forward to being able to chat a bit this time.
We know that there's been some super chats that we've been meaning to read for a while.
I've been getting a little bit older, a little bit gray.
But thank you for waiting patiently for us, Ruffians.
We're looking forward to chatting!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
And for our schedule!
Our schedule this week, unfortunately, you know with Moco-chan's migraine and everything, we weren't able to present this to you earlier.
But here's our schedule!
After our Super Chat meeting on the next day, Tuesday, it's a very, very
We're nervous, but we're gonna do our all, okay?
So please send us lots of good vibes, okay?
And then on Wednesday we have FUWAMOCO Morning!
And after that, FUWAMOCO, more homework.
We couldn't do our best.
And then on Thursday we have a collab all together with Alvin.
We're playing a game called School of Alvin.
Does this mean we get to go to school with Alvin?
I think before I thought it was a different game.
Are you scared now Mococo-chan?
I'm concerned.
Let's see how it goes!
What will we learn at school lab?
BAU BAU!
And on Friday, over on Koyori-senpai's channel, we're gonna be having an off club with her!
Our first off club with JP-senpai!
We're gonna be doing karaoke with Koyori-senpai.
And then over here, like we mentioned, we're having FUWAMOCO Morning with a very special guest, Koyori-senpai!
It'll be really exciting to see what kind of silly things we get up to all together.
You'll be partying now.
And then, afterwards in the evening, we're gonna be starting our own FUWAMOCO Minecraft channel.
You know I mentioned that now we both have one computer each.
So this means that both
Moco-chan and I, we can go and learn Minecraft!
Yeah, we can get our paws into the block world of Minecraft and find out just what it's like.
What do the blocks make, huh?
Yeah.
But we'll definitely need a lot of help from you, Ruffians, so we hope we'll have a really fun start of our Minecraft journey together.
BAU BAU!
And on Saturday, you know we have holo Dorokei coming up.
And I think we should practice a little bit, otherwise we're definitely gonna get caught.
So, we're gonna practice a little bit.
But, after that, in the evening, we have our FUWAMOCO Rock n' Rawr Party!
We were so, so excited to be able to sing some of our favorite anime songs with you.
But then, things didn't go quite as planned.
Don't really have control over...
Migrancia.
But it's okay because we're gonna have even more fun this weekend on Saturday.
And then on Sunday, we have the Day of the Big Horodoroki!
And we're gonna do our best to escape Travis Yamadori.
BAU BAU!
And that's our schedule for this week!
Thank you Ruffians!
And for Ruffians who are joining us through the iCountry, here is your FUWAMOCO would win!
It's...
BAU BAU!
Eternal Morning!
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning.
We hope it's gonna be an amazing week for all of us.
Let's make it that way, okay?
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians.
Extra!
BAU BAU!
What's he say?
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!